[Música]
despedimos a federico y saludamos a
mejores recortadores y bienvenido más
hablar de economía y un dato que acaba
de salir el dato de inflación en eeuu
así es que en los últimos 12 meses raúl
la inflación ahí aumentó un 8,6 por
ciento el aumento fue generalizado
siendo los índices de vivienda gasolina
y alimentos los que más contribuyeron
tras eso el pequeño descenso de abril el
índice de energía aumentó un 3,9 por
ciento durante el mes con un aumento del
4,1 por ciento en el índice de la
gasolina y el 4,1 en el de los alimentos
también la inflación está imponiendo
graves presiones financieras a las
familias estadounidenses obligándoles a
pagar mucho más por artículos como la
comida y la gasolina y el alquiler y
también reduciendo su capacidad para
permitirse artículos discrecionales
desde corte de pelo hasta el
entretenimiento el aumento de precios
obligó a la reserva federal de eeuu a
realizar lo que probablemente será la
serie más rápida de subidas de tipos de
interés en tres décadas esto con la idea
de frenar esta elevada inflación y
también china publicó el dato de
inflación o jorge y raúl el índice de
precios en mayo se mantuvo estable en
2,1 por ciento interanual al igual que
en abril la oficina de nacional de
estadística presenta el dato que muestra
una mejora de la situación
epidemiológica en china en mayo con
respecto a abril recordemos que ese país
sufrió los peores rebrotes del coi desde
el inicio de la pandemia la cifra fue
ligeramente inferior a los esperados por
los analistas que predecían un 2,2 por
ciento el índice de precios al productor
que mide los costos de los bienes en la
puerta de la fábrica aumentó un 6,4 por
ciento interanual en mayo las cifras en
modelo respecto al aumento del 8%
interanual que se registró en abril y
seguimos en asia vamos a acordar el psuv
porque miles de caminos están en huelga
por los precios de los combustibles
porque le pregunto cómo afecta esto a la
economía global bueno además de afectar
la productividad y la actividad
portuaria ahí es una nueva presión a las
cadenas de suministro que vienen
cargando desde la pandemia varias crisis
unos 7.200 camioneros o aproximadamente
el 30 por ciento del sindicato solidario
de camioneros de carga se declaró en
huelga del 7 de junio la protesta es por
el final de un sistema de ayudas activa
durante la pandemia que según ellos los
deje expuesto a perder la mayor parte de
sus ingresos debido a la subida del
precio de los combustibles
empresas como hyundai motor se han visto
afectados en la producción ya que los
camioneros se niegan a entregar los
componentes los camiones también
amenazan con ir a una huelga indefinida
si el gobierno no extiende la duración
del programa de ayuda que terminaría el
31 de diciembre la huelga supone el
primer reto económico para el presidente
johnson jude que lleva apenas un mes en
el poder y ya hemos seguimiento a la
crisis que dice vive en sri lanka hoy
naciones unidas advirtió que la crisis
económica allí podría derivar en una
grave crisis humanitaria así lo confirmó
ians leer quien es portavoz de la
agencia humanitaria de la onu aseguró
que están tomando las medidas para hacer
frente a esta situación el gobierno
decir lanka ha dicho que necesitan al
menos cinco mil millones de dólares en
los próximos seis meses para pagar los
artículos de primera necesidad ya que se
enfrentan a su peor crisis económica en
más de 70 años una delegación del fondo
monetario internacional va a visitar sir
lanka el 20 de junio para comenzar las
conversaciones sobre un préstamo que
podría aliviar por ahora esta crisis
actualmente el país insular tiene
escasez de combustible de gas de cocina
y médicamente los cálculos oficiales del
gobierno indican que requieren
3300 millones de dólares para importar
combustible unos 900 millones de dólares
para los alimentos 600 para los
fertilizantes y 250 millones para gas de
cocina la situación ha derivado en meses
de protestas y renuncias constantes de
varios funcionarios públicos entre ellos
dos hermanos del presidente región pacsa
y en japonés se reabrieron formalmente
este viernes al turismo la frontera tras
prohibir durante más de dos años la
entrada de los residentes y familiares
por ahora raúl esta entrada estará
limitada a grupos de turistas que
contratan planes de viaje con un
itinerario designado por agencias
registradas en el país y que proceden de
98 territorios catalogados por las
autoridades niponas como de riesgo
epidémico bajo entre estas naciones
podría estar eeuu reino unido españa
corea del sur o china los turistas deben
estar dispuestos a usar mascarillas y
otras medidas anti el virus la
renovación parcial del turismo
internacional en japón se está llevando
a cabo según unas directrices basadas en
un experimento que realizaron a finales
de mayo jorge cómo están los indicadores
económicos bueno empezamos con las
acciones indias que cayeron más de un 1%
su mayor pérdida semanal en un mes ya
que los inversores huyeron de los
activos de riesgo por el temor a que las
agresivas subidas de los tipos de
interés de parte de los bancos centrales
mundiales pues empeoran la situación
económica y en europa las acciones
europeas se mantienen en rojo
precisamente a la espera de este dato
que el recién salido de la inflación en
eeuu igual ser bueno acaba de abrir te
voy a contar en la próxima crónica cómo
irá así mejores no es un más adelante
entonces en nuestra segunda hora de
directo américa con más economía nos
vamos directo hasta los ángeles a
saludar a natalia cabrera
[Música]